[Music]
our daily cancellation begins with one
of our favorite characters in this
segment lizzo except that for once the
story has almost nothing to do with
lizzo being naked and overweight as we
know she's built a career around
exploring the intersection of fatness
and nakedness but that is not the point
today rather lizzo has attracted
controversy because of some of the
lyrics in her new hit single
girls
spelled g-r-r-r-l-s
as we know lizzo almost certainly cannot
define the word girl
but perhaps she can define the word girl
i don't know but this is not the word
that has caused severe offense
consternation emotional trauma and even
we must assume physical injury to some
of uh of lizzo's fans
that word well i'm not going to tell you
what that word is
partly because it's so deeply
problematic and shocking that i dare not
speak it out loud and also because i
thought it'd be a fun game
to play a one-minute clip of the song
for you and i want you to guess
which lyric was so offensive that lizzo
had to issue a public apology and
re-release the song with this word
changed
so listen closely
[Music]
get
[Music]
[Music]
bro
lizzo uh once again proving herself to
be the greatest poet of our time or any
time shakespeare may have written a
clever line or two but he never would
have thought to write something like
yeah we tussle mind your business zoo
zoo zoo zoo zulu that's my girl we ceos
and dancing like a ce ho
only lizzo could come up with something
so profound and moving if shakespeare
had written that they would have you
know assumed he was having a stroke or
something
but we're dancing around the point here
indeed i dare say we are we are even
dancing like ce hoes around the point
the question we still must answer is
which word out of all of the words you
just heard
though maybe bit too generous to call
all of those words
which was considered objectionable
enough to necessitate changing the song
she says the word multiple times she
uses the word hoe multiple times she
drops f-bomb she uses the term boozy
ratchet whatever the hell that means the
whole thing is about her engaging acts
of violence the song is one big threat
to jump some unspecified person and
commit felony assault or worse
and it's a potentially dangerous message
too because it might inspire other
out-of-shape women to pick random fights
with strangers thinking that they can
knock somebody out when they've never
thrown a punch in their lives and
probably will just break their wrists if
they tried so
is that the problematic message
or how about the part where lizzo says
that she's gonna cut a man's penis off
so that he can never have sex again
that's pretty disrespectful is that the
offensive part
the entire song from beginning to end is
vulgar stupid and violent
she could scrap the whole thing and
replace all the lyrics with the sounds
of feral cats fighting inside a dumpster
and it would be a vast improvement over
what you just heard so
what is the specific line that caused
the problem
well it turns out
that the only offensive word in that
song was the word
spazz
now if you recall at the very beginning
she sings hold my bag hold my bag do you
see this
i'm a spaz
again
pure poetry
but that's the problem right there i'm a
spaz quite literally the least offensive
word in the entire song one of the only
lyrics that that we don't have to bleep
on this show is the word that people are
offended by of course as entertainment
weekly reports the term spaz is now as
of about 12 seconds ago uh considered an
ableist slur
in fact in their report entertainment
weekly censors the word much like they
would if it was the n word or the f word
which is still written out
in the in the article
but spazz or the s word as it will now
be known is censored
many of lizzo's fans took her to task
for ableism in her song which promotes
felony violence and forced castration
but the real problem is the ableism
one of the fans leading the charge was
hannah
divani a disability advocate with
pronouns in her bio and she tweeted a
couple of days ago she said hey lizzo my
disability cerebral palsy is literally
classified as [ __ ] dipl
diplegia where specif spasticity
spasticity refers to unending painful
tightness in my legs your new song makes
me pretty angry and sad spazz doesn't
mean freaked out or crazy it's an
ableist slur
it's 20 22. do better
yes it's 2022.
you should know better than to use
harmless slang while threatening to cut
a man's penis off and beat stranger
senseless for no reason
please stick to communicating your
violent fantasies with vulgarities and
profanity just please just stick with
that
hannah is a woman of principle and
that's what she demands
and she got her way pretty quickly
yesterday lizzo reissued the song with
the s word replaced
and she made a public apology she posted
a twitter quote it's been brought to my
attention that there's a harmful word in
my new song girls let me make one thing
clear i never want to promote derogatory
language as a fat black woman in america
i've had many hurtful words used against
me so i overstand the power words can
have wait
i overstand
okay
i overstand the power words can have
whether intentionally or in my case
unintentionally i'm proud to say that
there's a new version of girls with a
lyric changed this is the result of me
listening and taking action
as an influential artist i'm dedicated
to being part of the change i have been
wanting and waiting to see in the world
only lizzo could manage to call herself
influential say that she's proud of
herself and brag about her wisdom and
insight
all in the context of an apology
truly the woman has turned virtue
signaling into an art form
she hasn't quite figured out how to make
her music into an art form but she's
basically the beethoven of virtue
signaling
at any rate yes uh be the change you
want to see in the world and lizzo
apparently
wants a world that is confused overly
sensitive and has its priorities exactly
backwards and upside down
and there's no doubt that she's
certainly helping in her own small way
to create precisely that kind of world
actually i need to correct myself
because i think we make a mistake when
we say that this sort of thing
is an example of people being sensitive
okay
and i and i say that all the time but
it's not exactly true because
traditionally
a sensitive person is somebody who is
empathetic kind
deeply aware of other people's feelings
and needs they're affected by and will
respond to
social cues
facial expressions and so on a sensitive
person is caring and compassionate
it's good to be sensitive in that way
and i say that as someone who is pretty
far to the other end of the spectrum for
better or worse
but i'm married to that sort of
sensitive person and i can say for sure
that the world would be a better place
if there were many more people like her
in the world like my wife that's why if
this was simply a case of people being
sensitive about the song
they might listen to it and object to
the whole thing observing that it's
vulgar and obscene and contributes to
the coarsening of our culture that would
be a sensitive and certainly not at all
unreasonable or baseless reaction to the
song and to almost everything else pop
culture produces but that's not what's
happening here
the people who who we often call
sensitive
are not sensitive at all
far from sensitive they're numb and dumb
they're more like robots filtering
everything through their leftist
programming and deciding based on those
algorithms to pretend to be offended by
all of the wrong things
this is how we end up in a culture
overrun by a bunch of inverted prudes
puritans who have been turned inside out
and flipped upside down
they have an endless appetite for
debauchery vulgarity stupidity obscenity
but they recoil in horror hard start
firing off angry letters because of some
random totally benign word or phrase
that happens to step on the
intersectional tripwire and set off the
pc alarms
they celebrate christina aguilera
dancing around in front of children with
a strap-on dildo but if she had her hair
braided like in a you know a
dreadlocks or something
then they would demand a public apology
for cultural appropriation and hairstyle
colonialism
this is the kind of sensitivity we're
talking about and it's not sensitivity
at all
but insanity
i think that's what we should really be
saying
and that is why not just lizzo but
everybody involved in this story
is today
cancelled if you enjoyed this video be
sure to give it a thumbs up and share it
with all your friends